chez moi vu d'en haut je me sens comme
au sommet d'une
montagne le monde tel que je le connais
se modifie et la vue est
splendide je me sens petite et grande à
la
fois petite face à ce qu'il me reste à
accomplir mais
grande face à ce que j'ai surmonté pour
arriver au
sommet comme mes peurs mes doutes
l'ivresse de la
performance j'ai le cœur qui bat mais
d'une vitalité que j'ai envie de vous
partager enveloppé dans C issu je peux
m'exprimer sans avoir à
parler en continuant de
d'inventer
d'innover et d'agir j'ai réussi à me
bâtir une vie libre et
créative pas à pas je relève les défis
de mon métier face à la passion que j'ai
pour cet
art
l'acrobatie c'est ma façon de développer
ma confiance personnelle ici j'is
précision vitesse maîtrise et
force c'est ici que j'ai réussi à
développer les habiletés pour trouver
l'équilibre dans toutes les sphères de
ma vie en grimpant toujours plus haut on
apprend à
vivre
isiera
volver
verteisa volver a
verte
quisiera
volver a
ver te extraño un poco más
que pero menos que
mañana Seas así
volve
aisver a
verte
atenacho ha un T
un a volver a
verisiera volver a
verte
quisiera exrañ un poco
más pero menos que
mañana no Seas así volve a
M quisiera volver a
verte aunque sea una vez más no te hagas
Elil dónde
estás quisiera volver a verte de dónde
cuáo yo estaré
ah
quisiera
vol
ateier